KATHERINE CLIFTON: Welcome to
Princeton, Class of 2016.
DEANA DAVOUDIASL: Coming to you
from the exotic location
of my backyard.
PAUL RILEY: From my hometown,
the great city of
Philadelphia.
MADHU RAMANKUTTY: Welcome
to Princeton
from Santiago, Chile.
SHAWON JACKSON: Hola y
felicidades from Honduras.
CHARISSA SHEN: Hello from the
sunny state of California.
What's up, 2016?
ANDY MARTENS: Welcome to
Princeton from Boston,
Massachusetts.
BENEDICT WAGSTAFF: From the
beautiful hills of Italy.
ELAN KUGELMASS: Welcoming the
Class of 2016 from the
Turquoise Trail in New Mexico.
ELEKTRA ALIVISATOS: I am
talking to you from the
beautiful island of
Paros in Greece.
DILLON SHARP: I wanted to give
you a warm welcome from my
hometown of Chicago.
GAVIN COOK: Right now, I'm in
Jingshan Park, which is one of
the very few hills in
Beijing, overlooking
the Forbidden City.
STEPHEN STOLZENBERG: And welcome
to Princeton from
Dusseldorf, Germany.
JOHN MCNAMARA: And welcome
from the Jersey Shore.
BRUCE EASOP: Hi,
Class of 2016.
Welcome from your USG.
My name is Bruce Easop,
and I'm USG president.
I'm here in beautiful
Copenhagen, Denmark, for the
summer before heading back for
my senior year at Princeton.
So the first thing
you're probably
thinking is, what is USG?
USG stands for Undergraduate
Student Government.
And I like to think of our job
as building connections.
We connect student ideas to
the administrators who can
make them happen.
We bring students together
through campus-wide social
events, plus we like to connect
you guys to your
representatives through
videos like these.
So if you have any questions
or ideas that you want to
happen, feel free to check out
our online suggestion box at
usg.princeton.edu.
Or contact anyone
in this video.
But first, we have a few
things to say to you.
So here are some people who
couldn't wait to welcome you
guys to the Princeton
community.
BENEDICT WAGSTAFF: Just wanted
to send a message of welcome
to all of you to the
Princeton fam.
PAUL RILEY: I want to
congratulate you all on
officially becoming
Princetonians.
SHAWON JACKSON: I'm super
excited that you all chose to
come here, and I know you're
going to have a really, really
great four years.
KATHERINE CLIFTON: I'm sure you
know you're very lucky to
be here at Princeton.
But remember, Princeton
is also in turn very
lucky to have you.
JOHN MCNAMARA: As you begin your
time at Princeton, the
best advice I can give to you is
to take time to reflect on
where you are and where
you're going.
SHAWON JACKSON: Have a
random conversation
with just about anyone.
People at Princeton have so many
diverse experiences, from
travelling all over the world
to doing the Rubik's Cube in
10 seconds.
And you really do learn a
great deal from them.
So instead of staying up until
4 o'clock doing a paper, stay
up until 4 o'clock talking
with some of
your closest friends.
ELEKTRA ALIVISATOS: Definitely
take advantage of all the
opportunities, academically and
socially, that you have at
the school.
ZHAN OKUDA-LIM: Ultimately,
there are just so many people
to meet, so many places to go,
and so many things to do.
And while, of course, you must
balance your time, I encourage
you to take advantage of
the many opportunities
available to you.
PAUL RILEY: As you prepare to
pack up your things and move
to Princeton, where you'll spend
the next four years of
your life, I encourage you all
to always remain humble and to
remain grateful for such
an amazing opportunity.
JOHN MCNAMARA: Combine that with
being yourself, working
hard, asking for help when you
need it, and of course, taking
a little time to enjoy
it along the way.
I promise your time at Princeton
will be nothing
short of fantastic.
BENEDICT WAGSTAFF: Enjoy
yourselves at
OA, CA, or at home.
Finish up your summers
with style.
DEANA DAVOUDIASL: We really
can't wait to meet you all,
and see you in a few weeks.
ZHAN OKUDA-LIM: Welcome to
Princeton University, and I
hope to see you around campus.
GAVIN COOK: Hope you have
a great summer.
Get excited.
I trust you'll love Princeton
as much as I do, and I look
forward to meeting
you in the fall.
ELEKTRA ALIVISATOS:
[INAUDIBLE]
summer, and see you on campus.
PAUL RILEY: I hope that you all
are enjoying the last few
weeks of summer.
I hope that you all are anxious
and excited about this
transition and this next
chapter of your life.
DILLON SHARP: So go out, meet
new people, find new friends,
and find some activities that
you're interested in.
And really have a great time.
Welcome to Princeton.
CHARISSA SHEN: So all right.
I'm excited to meet you guys.
Make you sure come find me
when you get to campus.
Hope you enjoyed your summers.
We'll see you in the fall.
KATHERINE CLIFTON: Have a
wonderful freshman year.
BENEDICT WAGSTAFF:
And get ready to
rage for lawn parties.